well in a very large part thanks to
oversimplified we did it
we reached 50k subs thank you everyone
so much for subscribing and giving my
channel a try do you celebrate I have
made this extra video for all of you so
you can laugh at me because this video
is all about mistakes I've made in my
videos after all I'm human I think and I
make mistakes as everyone else and even
though I try my best to catch these
mistakes some are bound to slip through
and make it into the final product
with that said I would like to say that
when I do catch a mistake or one has
pointed out to me by you guys I always
put a correction in the description so
it's good practice to check that before
you write yet another comment about a
mistake I already know about and have
mentioned in the description without
further ado let's begin the first few
videos I made were more of just
Wikipedia narration so there isn't much
I could have gotten specifically wrong
in them but I did oversimplify certain
things to such a point that you could
call it being wrong for example in my
ability saw a video I just have a
graphic saying that Bohemia Austria and
Hungary interchanged control of
Bratislava a bunch during an unspecified
period this is in the simplest of terms
true but I don't give a date when these
exchanges of control happen or how often
they happened or even in what order they
happened so you can see how it can be
counted as a mistake but such
oversimplifications I'm not going to put
into this video because there's a lot of
them in my early video since I wasn't
really sure back then what I was doing
however I will mention one thing which
isn't really a mistake but bothers me to
this day in the video about Edinburgh
here I meant to say no that's George but
you know a spelling error mated George
whatever that means my fourth video
about that I came against a lot of
mistakes but I already addressed that in
my history of Iceland series so I won't
mention it here just know it's not a
good video the only reason I keep it up
is because I want people to see that I'm
actually making an effort and improving
production and research on my videos and
I didn't just start off making good
videos on the contrary the early videos
were pretty bad now my history of hockey
video had a pretty bad mistake
I said Hurley was a British sport which
if you know anything about Hurley and
its fan
meant that I got a bunch of angry
comment now in my defense I meant that
Hurley was a birth Dalek and Irish sport
as it evolved from an earlier Celtic
game played on the British Isles but I
made unfortunate mistake of thinking
British and pythonic was the same thing
which it is not
hence the mistake another stupid mistake
was math related and my only known
history video on the channel I averaged
the numbers of three different costs
depending on the type of university
without staking to account the student
population in the US isn't evenly
distributed between public and private
institutions and of in-state and
out-of-state students even though I
treated them as such that was done on my
part I'm not good at math and there's a
reason I stayed with jazz history for
this channel after that my Slavic video
many people got angry about this one it
doesn't really have a mistake per se as
I'm just stating theories and there
isn't enough evidence to definitely
support any of them but I'm putting it
here as a mistake because I just didn't
explain well what I was trying to say in
the video which is my fault
no one is arguing that the Slavs when
they emerged on the political stage
during the migration period didn't come
from somewhere north of the D ester and
west of the nyet better they definitely
did what I was trying to talk about is
when and from where did the Slavs come
from into that area they couldn't have
been there for all eternity were they
there since the fifth century BC or did
they come there in the third century CE
or any order date did they come from the
north or the east they already split
with the pouts or not etc we just don't
know hence all the different theories I
talked about in the video next is my
Western Slavic history video and no this
one doesn't have any mistakes you
boneheaded nationalists are thinking of
it in fact as a pretty dumb mistake I
call the first ruling dynasty of Poland
the Mieszko dynasty which it is not it's
the Piast dynasty Mischka is just the
first non disputed king of the Piast
dynasty quick mistake in a blueblood
video I called Hispania Hispaniola which
it obviously isn't as Hispaniola is an
island in the Caribbean but in my
defense there are pretty similar names
the next one is again technically not a
mistake what I think is worth talking
about it refers to my use of the Red
Cross on a white background to represent
Columbus's ships no one actually really
knows what symbol if any Columbus had on
his sails especially during the first
voyage however almost all depictions of
the voyages showed their ships having a
red cross on a white background this
would be very possible as two of the
three ships were Carvel's which are of
portuguese origin who used a red Knights
Templar cross plus to add to this Genoa
where Columbus was from also had a mane
symbol of a red cross on top of that the
Spanish have been known to use the red
cross on a white background as well
although for damn it was supposed to
symbolize the cross of Saint James which
depending on how drawn can look very
similar to the Templars cross all this
means that it is very likely that
Columbus had a red cross on a white
background on his ships but again we
just don't know for sure next is New
York City history video this mistake is
a good one I pointed to 500 fifth avenue
building and called it the rockefeller
center and no one noticed for like a
week before a bunch of New Yorkers
started typing I'm a [ __ ] so yeah made
a mistake there another mistake is in my
Eastern Slavic history of video where I
say the Scandinavians acquired the
knowledge of making Damascus steel from
India through the Eastern European
waterways so they could create their
famous old bird swords
well for one knowledge of creating
Damascus steel comes from the Middle
East not India and the Vikings never
actually made Damascus steel as the old
bird swords never actually were true
Damascus they were sometimes considered
as pattern-welded Falls Damascus steel
which is a form of crucible steel but
isn't actually true Damascus steel so
what I meant to say is that the Vikings
acquired knowledge to create crucible
steel through the Eastern European
waterways which unlike Damascus steel
dust originated from India the last
mistake I'll point out is in my Mexican
War of Independence video where I show a
picture of Prince Pedro announcing
Brazilian independence and claimed it to
be the spanish liberal revolution right
after that I show a picture of the
Portuguese government claiming it to be
the Spanish Liberal government that's
where I will in this video thank you all
so much for 50,000 subscribers and
here's to another 50,000 oh and I have a
patreon you can check out see you next
time
[Music]